You know there's something
else I wanna talk about here,
just mention briefly.
Folks, as you're probably all aware,
we live in security conscious
times here in America.
And I just wanna take a second and applaud
the security force here at NBC.
They do an amazing job.
You probably met some of
them when you were coming in.
Really great.
(audience applauding)
They do a good job.
Crack security team here.
Crack security team, and I
pass these people everyday.
I see the security guys,
the men and the women
that are protecting is
here in the building.
And I see 'em and they're
doing such a good job
and I started to think the other day,
wouldn't it be interesting
if I could see what it takes
to be a top flight security guard
here at 30 Rockefeller Center, you know?
I wanted to know if I had the right stuff,
if I could do it.
So folks, guess what I did?
I joined up for a night.
That's right, I gave up
my cushy late night job
and I joined in on the security force here
at Rockefeller Center.
I brought a camera crew with
me and this is what happened.
Take a look.
(upbeat music)
(audience laughing)
I'm here at the main
station for NBC security
and I'm here with Oliver Gordon,
one of our top security people.
How are you sir?
I'm fine tonight, thank you.
Let me ask you, tonight for one night only
I'm joining the force.
Is it known as the force?
No, it's known as security.
Can we say that I'm
part of an elite squad?
Well, that's a little stretching it.
The Q ring, the inner ring, the Q ring.
All that stuff that's good, that's good.
That's okay?
That's okay.
One of the greatest thing
about security guards
is they get to carry
around that ring of keys
that sort of open anything.
Do you have one of those?
Oh yeah we got our keys.
What do you got?
Not many, about 10 keys on there.
Let me see that, hold
that up, jingle that.
I got about 10 on there, that's all.
Yeah, check this out.
(audience laughing)
This opens every door in New York City.
You got the master ring.
And Staten Island.
I also use this at Christmas time.
(keys jingling)
(keys clanging)
(audience laughing)
Men, office down, officer down.
So how would you say my
first day is going so far?
A little tricky.
This is where if there's gonna be trouble
it's gonna start here
and it's gonna end here,
is that right?
That's right.
Someone shows their ID
and then it shows up on this monitor.
Do you check the face that shows up here
with the face of the guy coming through?
That's right.
If that face doesn't
match up, what do you do?
I stop them.
You stop them, how do you stop them?
Just tell them to stop.
No, elbow to the throat,
soft part of the throat right here.
Drive the tip of the elbow
until you feel the back of the throat.
That means you've crushed their windpipe.
You got it?
(audience laughing)
(upbeat music)
(bell ringing)
Do you hear a noise?
Yeah.
Come here.
Let's check it out.
Hello, how are you?
Okay!
Everything all right?
Yes, sir!
(audience laughing)
But she ran away.
Yeah.
Doesn't seem suspicious to you?
Have you seen here before?
She's been here about five years now.
Not a long time when you think about it.
Not long at all.
Sometimes people put in five years
just to make everybody
comfortable and then chop chop!
(upbeat music)
(audience laughing)
This is the nerve center
for NBC security right here.
Can you tell me who is
this guy right here?
Who's that gentleman?
That's Officer Brown.
Officer Brown, Officer
Brown, do you hear me?
Yes, I hear you.
This is Conan O'Brien speaking to you
from "Late Night with Conan O'Brien"
starring me, Conan O'Brien.
How are you?
I'm feeling good, everything is clear.
Could you give me a wave right now
so I can confirm it's you?
(audience laughing)
Hi, Conan.
Do me a favor, just pat
this guy on the head
who's walking through right now.
Give him a little pat on the head!
(audience laughing)
(Conan laughing)
That was nice, that was very good.
All right I'm proceeding to other levels.
If there's any problems at
all, my code word tonight
is I'm known as the red fox or night fox.
All right red fox, copy loud and clear.
I prefer night fox to be honest.
Okay, Conan.
♪ Loving you ♪
(knocking)
Hello!
Hold this.
That really hurt.
(audience laughing)
And I accomplished nothing.
Can you unlock this women's room?
Yeah, I have the key.
I bet you do!
(audience laughing)
You dog.
Look at you laughing, you're
like oh I got the key!
Oh look and it's really worn
like you've used it a lot.
(audience laughing)
You see Conan merchandise,
but when's the last time
you saw some "Dateline" merchandise?
I don't think anything.
I don't think I can remember any.
Right, you know what
I'm sayin'? (laughing)
High five me.
Okay I've never done that before.
That was weird, your hand is moist.
Just gonna look in the bag
just to make sure that that's,
is that okay?
A fork.
(audience laughing)
No forks, sir, you know that.
This is the "Dateline" offices right here.
There's Stone Phillips right there.
Have you met Stone?
Yes I have, I work with him.
Nice guy, right?
Yeah he's good, he's a good guy.
Kind of robotic.
Have you ever actually
seen him take nourishment?
No, I've never seen him.
Really?
No.
'Cause there's this theory
that he's powered by dry cell batteries.
Not that I know of.
He might be a robot.
You've never seen him
drink water or eat food?
I've seen him drink water, yes.
Did he put the water near his mouth
and then say, "What's
that over there, Oliver?"
and you looked away and
when you turned back
the glass was empty but there
was a puddle on the floor?
No, I have not seen none of that.
Robots do that to distract humans.
Hey, hey man how you doing?
Good to see you sir, how are you?
Good to see you!
What are you doing?
Let's go.
Okay, thank you sir.
Julie, I'm being frisked
by Conan O'Brien right now.
I'm being frisked by Conan.
Sir, I didn't do anything I promise.
Do you know this man you're
talking to right now?
Ryan?
Do you confirm that?
Yeah.
You're on your way, Ryan.
All right thank you sir.
You have a...
Thank you very much,
appreciate it.
You have a tight ass.
(audience cheering)
I want everyone to return to their homes!
God bless you all!
(upbeat music)
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
I think I did a lot of good.
Our thanks to our security gang
for helping us out with that.
When we come back, Heath Ledger is here!